francis lalanne qui ces dernières années
c'est beaucoup illustré pour ses combats
politiques a été l'auteur d'une sortie
de route lors d'un rassemblement ce
week-end donc je vous prends proche de
commettre un délit
c'est à nice que le chanteur a pris la
parole devant 350 manifestants réunis
sous le drapeau du collectif bas les
masques pour nos enfants
des spectateurs qui ne respectent pas
les distances entre eux et auquel
francis lalanne a finalement demandé de
s'embrasser son masque je vous propose
de vous embrasser les uns les autres
partager face à ces images relayées par
la presse de nombreux médecins pris à la
gorge dans les services de réanimation
décidé de réagir
c'est le cas par exemple du docteur jean
paul hamon qui est monté au créneau
alors colère des médecins faut-il
condamner francis lalanne bonsoir
amine ça juste aniche alcine il ya des
gens qui disent mais pas d'alliance
comment ça se fait parce que si on a
interdiction de mettre l'alliance
pendant la diffusion ça fait soixante
douze fois que je le dis avec vous avec
qui avec les jambes et qui ainsi sa
course et je les dis ou moins joue dur
on joue sur 72 soit alors je vois la
montre à émettre l'alliance à arriver
dans un instant juste il ya beaucoup de
gens qui nous demandent pourquoi vous
n'est pas d'aller au 13e fois est merci
en tout cas nice et si vous revenez nous
voir dans deux semaines obligatoirement
juste sur francis lalanne bains jean
paul hamon il est extrêmement énervé et
il va nous rejoindre dans un instant
guillon match qu'on va que les gens
défonce francis l'anam j'ai le droit de
faire ce qu'il veut et par une partie de
la population qui n'en peut plus qui a
envie de s'embrasser qui a envie de
faire la fête et c'est toujours les
mêmes excuses des médecins et vous allez
dire des collègues va dire oui vous
rendez compte de l'état des hôpitaux
vous rendez compte et c'est bon c'est
toujours les mêmes et ce qu il ya aussi
des gens qui en ont marre qu'ils ont
envie de vivre normalement ça dépend
qui ne vise pas normalement donc laissé
le représenter c'est ces gens là et
puisque les gens le font encore fait
alors et donc durable disant ça parce
qu'on fait en demandant jambes
éventuellement les en les exhortant de
s'embrasser tu prends des risques pour
les gens aussi en fait ça fait qu'on
dise à la faut passer à autre chose
c'est bon mais sauf que c'est le concret
c'est la non en fait il est criminel il
est inconscient il est m il est
irresponsable il devra les gens dans les
ehpad
mais tu es dans ta freebox personnes
plutôt connecter à n'importe quoi dans
la rue pour reporter une sorte de gens
quoi l'amour vous êtes énervé myrtle
generali j'adore quand vous venez sachez
le vous êtes président d'honneur de la
fédération des médecins de france et
président d'honneur également de notre
émission que s'achéve emile images de
france les images de consiste à elle je
sais qu'à vous ont choqué vous êtes
énervé
oui c'est vrai que c'est une bonne idée
de faire chanter dans les épais bien
c'est bien ce serait bien non parce que
franchement honnêtement c'est pas comme
si les réalités pas plein c'est pas
comme si la pandémie était là je
comprends que les gens aient envie de
chanter de de se marrer mais là quand
ils sont tous sans masque alors que là
nous on a tous en train de serrer les
fesses en train de se dire est ce qu on
est on est déjà 5000 m en réanimation il
y en a plus de 2500 1 m pour pour qu'on
atteigne la la le pic de la première
vague d'un souvenir vague là on avait
été obligé de confiner et vous faut
savoir que si on arrête si on confinait
maintenant il faudrait qu'un jour pour
enrayer la pourriez la montée là on a
100 150 mètres de puces en réanimation
tous les jours donc dans quinze jours ça
va faire quoi 1000 1500 cru s'en va être
à 6500 donc 6500 là on est vraiment au
taquet et puis surtout se dire on tenir
compte c'est que les gens qui bossent en
reais commencera un peu en avoir plein
le dos il ya des gens qui ont des gens
qui se barre avant la première vague on
pouvait faire venir des gens de province
qui venait donner un coup de main des
personnels de province mais là tout
leiria son plein l'été puis sont ils
semblant d'être où ils ont ils ont la
peur de venir parce que leur lot
réanimation sont pleines ils ont peur de
dégarnir trop les hausses tôt alors
qu'avant il y avait des gens qui
venaient de l'ouest qui n'est du
sud-ouest qui venait à paris ou qui
venait même à mulhouse
là on peut pas et puis ça fait un an que
ça dure donc les gens ils en ont un peu
marre vous répondez quoi ceux qui disent
que qui parle comme trentaine de liberty
qui voient leur prix leur liberté c'est
vrai écoutez là moi je suis venu en moto
tout à l'heure c'était plutôt sympa ça
sentait temps en temps le barbecue en
fonte avec les tp des dehors dans le
jardin bon c'est sympa on a envie de
sortir on comprend bien
mais là il faut être raisonnable on peut
bon 6e si vous êtes dans un grand jardin
faut pas le dire à leurs mains mais vous
pouvez être 8 ou 10 à condition que vous
respectiez les aînés les mesures bâle
les mesures barrières que l'on soit un
taux que vous fassiez pas de bisous et
c'est là en ce moment la joie qu'en les
joies des gens de 80 85 ans qui viennent
me voir en consultance tapez le code bon
on se marre bon les gens is more as tu
as beaucoup de ça peut être aussi sympa
de se taper le coup de se faire dès sur
des grosses d'embrassades si vous
essayez ça quand même lol on n'est pas
obligé de jouer au con comme marescaux
comme francis lalanne je sais qu'il faut
condamner chanteur ou juste voilà leur
prénom mais là écoutez franchement le
type il ya une position bon il séduit
des gens vont y a des gens qu'il aime
c'est bien pour lui bien sûr il allait
demander aux mecs de s'embrasser alors
que là ils sont déjà sans masque qui
sont tout près les uns des autres
déjà l'extérieur c'est vrai qu'on a
moins de chances de 2,2 chopé le virus à
l'extérieur à condition d'être à
distance
elle a demandé aux gens de s'embrasser
c'est inconscient quoi c'est que demain
emmanuel macron paris qui va prendre la
parole penser qu'il va rencontrer
totalement comme en mars dernier où pas
c'est pas sûr c'est pas si vous voulez
autant moi mais j'ai pas critiquer le
fait qu'il n'est pas confiné la première
fois parce que il a tenu qu on avait dit
en février hélicon qu'il a tenu compte
de l'état psychiatrique des français
vous savez il ya ya pas mal de gens qui
déprime et là on aurait effectivement pu
peut-être vider un peu de rien mais on
aurait rempli les hôpitaux
psychiatriques il ya des gens qui ce qui
n'en peuvent plus 1 et donc ça et c'est
pas un hasard si un psychiatre qui est
rentré dans le comité scientifique en ce
moment envoyé et je pense sincèrement
qu'il a eu raison pas confiné et il a eu
raison de tenir
et pourtant dieu sait si j'ai été
suffisamment critique français qui va
tenir encore il peut tenir parce que
tout ce que vous nous dites moi je pense
qu'il va falloir prendre une décision
dans les huit jours il j'entendais hier
un hospitalier qui disait qu' il ya des
piscines qui montaient que bon ça à sa
grain mais ça grimperait moins que donc
au lieu de grimper comme ça s'aggrave
près comme ça donc on this is à g comme
ça on ne peut encore tenir peut-être
huit jours et si dans huit jours ça
tient pourra peut-être tenir quinze
jours
donc c'est vrai que bon c'est pas simple
et puis toute façon c'est pas simple de
gouverner en ce moment on savait bon
jouer à la récupération politique
j'ai vu ce qu'a fait la langue j'ai vu
ce qu'avait philippe où il y avait moins
de monde pour filippo mais moi c'est ça
qui est moins bien c'est ça
c'est ça qui est touchante moins bien et
chante moi bien c'est vrai c'est vrai
sur l'astra zeneca on se dit quoi bon on
se dit que c'est dommage qu'ils aient eu
des thromboses mai mais en même temps le
bénéfice le bénéfice risque il est
largement en faveur du vaccin largement
donc un largement ce qu'il faut c'est
pas vacciner les gens en dessous de 55
ans d'accord bon mais maintenant ce
qu'il faudrait surtout c'est qu'ils
aient des vaccins parce qu'en ce moment
on se demande si le gouvernement
il est pas fan de fernand raynaud vous
savez peut-être connu ça les croissants
1 alors le vous regardez c'est donc avec
des croissants il n'y a pas de vaccin on
va arriver à m on va mettre davantage de
vaccinateurs ya pas il fera pas de
vaccin on va mettre davantage de lieux
de vaccination
et puis dire qu'on va vacciner au stade
de france pour vacciner mille personnes
par jour c'est ce qu'on fait à clamart
tous les jours donc si vous laissez pas
la peine d'ouvrir le tas de france à fin
du monde dans le stade c'est bien on a
des vaccins ou pas on est comment sur
les vaccins les vaccins pas trop sur les
vaccins on n'a pas trop où on aimerait
bien que les vaccins arrivent ça sert à
rien de confiner sur la pâte vaccin
aussi à la wii d'une peur mais là les
vaccins les vaccins vont arriver mais là
encore si vous voyez la communication du
gouvernement est tellement mauvaise
quand on va finir par croire que que
c'est à cause de commandes de vaccins
on est complètement tributaire des dd de
l'industrie pharmaceutique
alors ceci étant je pense que bon on
peut quand même donné un petit peu
d'espoir aux français c'est à dire que
la l'industrie pharmaceutique s'est mise
en route l'industrie pharmaceutique a
commencé à produire du vaccin et je
pense que d'ici mois d'octobre coiffure
fois racer vacciner pascal et lorient
mais oui mais il y en a
non mais il y en a assez quoi c'est à
dire que là je pense sincèrement que si
on tient encore un mois ça va être bon
ça va faire comme c'est lé cet été ça va
se calmer mais sauf que là on aura
vacciner un maximum de personnes et que
au mois d'octobre déjà je pense que les
fabricants de vaccins sont en train
d'adapter par rapport aux variants je
pense qu'on va avoir droit à une
nouvelle piqûre dans l'année qui vient
mais que cette fois ci on n'aura pas à
courir après les vaccins parce que
l'industrie pharmaceutique ce sera mise
en route assez dans l'industrie de près
en produira suffisamment de cet été ça
reste passé commande pour ckoi pourra
partir en vacances ou pas
en camargue j'espère qu'il ya
suffisamment de place vous pourrez faire
des barbecues avec penser que cet été
parce qu'on commence on commença à se
dire aussi qu est ce qui va se passer la
saison
sicotte un peu de revivre un petit peu
les mêmes mois de d'avril louis joue
moins que l'année dernière
c'est vrai que vous pourrez danser mais
vous danserez de hors jeu changent
vraiment un grand que dans ce raid or il
ya des salles et pour les boîtes de nuit
sais c'est mal barré mais mais pour le
reste je pense que vous regardez ce qui
se passe quand même en angleterre ce qui
se passe en israël chère en israël les
boîtes de nuit sont verts de légende et
cetera parce qu'ils sont vaccinés mari
donc là je pense que quand il y aura
suffisamment de personnes vaccinées
je pense que septembre mois de fin août
fin août début septembre ça on
commencera enfin respirer et vacances à
commencer les vacances à 40 ans julie
pour compte en juillet c'est nicolas
j'ai une question à vous poser par
rapport à votre première question les
enseignants aujourd'hui ne sont pas
vaccinés vous le savez un ouais c'est
insoutenable ce qui se passe dans les
écoles
c'est le moment comment demain il peut
prendre une autre décision que de
confiner non non c'est à dire combien il
ya encore des solutions seigneur mais là
aussi cela aussi on n'a pas dissipé
confinera pas demain je suis d'accord
avec docteur ramon ben moi je pense
qu'il va rester sur sa ligne et vient ce
trou en espérant une petite voix la
comédie une piscine et que ça voilà
ok ça passe encore et qu'après on arrive
dans les beaux jours et que ça passe et
qu'ils aient arrive à ne pas confiné je
pense qu'il a cette petite fenêtre de
tir en corse mais paul est pour les
écoles c'est pareil si vous voulez les
gamins les gamins ils ont vachement
trinquer c'est vrai que c'est il a
raison de vouloir maintenir les écoles
ouvertes mais quand même on sait depuis
le mois de novembre que le variant
anglais il est là sûr que ça touche les
enfants
hélas quand j'entendais ce lycée de la
croix en seine saint denis où il y avait
pas mal de gens contaminés
le recteur disait on va faire des tests
massif bien sûr alors je lui ai posé la
question j'ai mais qu'est ce que vous
allez faire des gamins qui vont être
positif il doit les remettre dans leur
famille si vous avez raison mais qui est
bon est à 5 dans 50 mètres carrés il ya
toute la famille va y avoir droit
alors que là ce serait pas très très
difficile de rouvrir parce qu'on va pas
mettre les mecs à l'hôtel des gamins de
8 10 ans par les maîtres à l'hôtel mais
on pourrait rouvrir des centres de
vacances à toutes les municipalités ont
des centres de vacances juste jean-paul
à manger manger mais j'avais je parle
avec un ami ce matin on se disait est ce
qui pourrait pas une enviable se servir
des vacances de pâques l'a essayé de
vraiment de vacciner le maximum
d'enseignements pour reprendre
tranquillement ensuite derrière est-ce
que c'est ce que sait on des usagers
c'est clair que si on veut maintenir les
écolos were qu'il faut vacciner en
priorité les assesseurs la ccxr si c'est
clair qu'il faut le faire parce que
c'est ce qui va faire qu'il faut faire
mais en décidant finalement des gamins
pour pas les remettre dans leur famille
moi j'ai eu deux familles où les gamins
sont arrivés avec le virus à la maison
ils ont eu droit à tous les quatre ils
ont eu droit un 6 à 4 dans 50 mètres
carrés vous pouvez pas respecté les
mesures barrières strictement c'est sûr
que quand vous avez des gamins quand vie
de 10 ans et j'aimerais que moi bernard
montiel porte parole du gouvernement je
pense que le président ne va par
confiner comme en mars dernier
je pense que il va guère rester sur ses
lignes et parce qu'il a ce pour lui on
va pas se mentir il ya aussi de la
politique dans tout ça et pour lui ce
serait une petite victoire de dire j'ai
réussi à ne pas confiné à passer entre
les gouttes à faire un confinement qui
s'est pas trop vu et peut-être repartir
derrière avec comme vous avez dit quoi
qu'il arrive on l'a vu les nerfs
s'abaisser un petit peu lors de deux
mois de juin du mois de juillet ça vient
ça a bien baissé dans cette tendance à
rennes en maths et sur ça on sortait
d'un confinement exactement mais mais
bon ça va ça va baisser mais les gens
vont être vaccinés et donc les gens ils
seront de moins en moins ça va
contaminer
donc il
le tire peut-être qu'un jour c'est ça
moi je pense que si on réussit à tenir
des quinze jours je pense qu'il va
tenter le coup le président s'est
employé à condition qu'ils aient pas dé
la longue liste de la vanne c'est
n'importe quoi on le sait et en plus
c'est une personnalité j'ai entendu dire
que rené la taupe peut faire la même
chose
l'interrogateur c'est une personnalité
il a une responsabilité et la scea
frustré yfrog on l'a déjà conseillère en
revanche pour en ce qui concerne la
vaccination
évidemment sur la base du volontariat
des enseignants il ya 800 mille
enseignants en france et un million de
au total de personnels qui travaillent
les cantines etc les rassure et c'est
prévu blanquer relativement proposé de
les faire vacciner leur peau ce serait
bon robin merci jean paul hamon tout